The cast of "Peaky Blinders" has
featured, and tragically lost,
some true legends. Here are some of the actors
from the series you may not know passed away.
The late Karl Shiels might not be a name that
"Peaky Blinders" fans immediately recognize,
but he played a key role in the show's
very first season. He portrayed Irish
Republican Army member Ryan, who
approaches Tommy with his cousin
to make an offer for the machine
guns the Peaky Blinders stole.
"We'd pay good money."
"You have good money?"
"We have the collections from the pubs."
Born in Dublin, Shiels was a huge presence
in the Irish live theater scene for years,
working in all manner of productions as both an
actor and director. He earned many accolades over
the course of his life, including a 1999 award
for best actor at the Dublin Theatre Festival.
One of his most prominent roles was that of Robbie
Quinn in the Irish soap opera "Fair City," whom
he played for nearly 200 episodes. Shiels passed
away in his sleep in July 2019 at the age of 47.
Jeremiah Jesus has got to be one of the
most beloved "Peaky Blinders" characters,
even though his screen time is relatively
limited. A street preacher, war veteran,
and honorary Peaky Blinder, Jeremiah always
seems to show up when he's needed the most.
"God says he don't deal with Small Heath, sir."
"Good man."
It's hard to imagine anyone other than the late
Benjamin Zephaniah playing Jeremiah. Though he
appeared in other TV shows, Zephaniah's artistic
pursuits transcended acting. He was a musician,
a poet, and an outspoken critic of
English imperialism. After the death of
reggae superstar Bob Marley, Zephaniah was the
first new singer to record with his old band,
The Wailers. He also hosted a concert
for Nelson Mandela in 1996. In 2003,
Zephaniah was offered a prestigious
OBE, or Order of the British Empire,
but rejected it, decrying the United Kingdom's
extensive history of slavery and colonialism.
"I've been writing to connect with people,
not to impress governments and monarchy."
Zephaniah died of a brain tumor in December
2023 at the age of 65. According to a post
made on his official Instagram account,
his wife was by his side when he passed.
In "Peaky Blinders," Tim Woodward played Lord
Suckerby, a member of Parliament accused by
Tommy Shelby of despicable crimes in Season
5. He may have only ever appeared in a single
"Peaky Blinders" episode, but Woodward had
an impressive career that spanned the stage,
film, and television. He's probably best
remembered as the star of "Wings," a BBC
war drama from the 1970s, but he appeared in
dozens of movies and TV shows over his career.
In November 2023, Woodward died of cancer
at 70 years old. He's survived by his wife,
Amanda, and his five children.
The acting world lost a true titan when Helen
McCrory died of breast cancer in April 2021. She
was only 52 years old. Across her career, McCrory
built a reputation as one of the best actors of
her era. In between critically acclaimed turns on
stage, she worked on a ton of major TV series and
films, including the "Harry Potter" franchise,
"Penny Dreadful," and "Hugo," among many, many
others. But of all her roles, none stands taller
than that of Polly Gray on "Peaky Blinders."
For much of the show, Polly is practically a dual
protagonist with Tommy, providing a veteran voice
that can stand up to him and give counsel when
he leads the family astray. Every scene where
McCrory gets to take up space as Polly — and
there are a lot of them — is a high point.
"I will wear high heels so
you can hear my approach on
the cobblestones and have time to repent."
After her death, series
creator Steven Knight said:
"Helen was one of the great actors of
her generation. She was so powerful
and controlled and this is so sad."